well my talk of the table is hbo's
comedy hacks have you guys seen it
it's pretty good it's uh seen and
nominated for
15 emmy awards count them 15.
one of them is for actress hannah
einbinder
who plays comedy writer ava daniels her
life
unravels after an insensitive tweet got
her fired
from her job well the only work she can
get afterward is writing for
comedy diva deborah vance played by gene
smart
so here's part of that job interview
take a listen
what's your favorite joke of mine
man you know
that's so hard well it shouldn't be i've
written over 30 000 just pick one
uh you know what
i would have to say that your tv show is
my personal favorite thing that you've
ever done
you mean my sitcom from 1973
you've seen it oh yeah
i mean i've yeah i've seen
um clips clips
wonderful actress and stand-up comedian
hannah einbinder joins us now good
morning and congratulations on your
first
emmy nomination hannah have you ever
even been in a situation like that
before
you played it so well oh
thank you um that's so lovely thank you
for having me by the way
um have i been in a situation like that
before
i mean honestly most of my jobs before
hacks were like
coffee shop slash retail so it's a
pretty straightforward thing
you know yeah and not a lot of like
research there right well obviously the
emmy nomination
is huge what was your reaction to that
news where were you when you found out
um i was here i was here in california
in l.a where i live
where i'm from and you know they
announced these things pretty early in
the morning or
early for for you such as myself
you guys are up yeah you guys are ready
to go you're alert
me i'm what's happening it's 8 a.m you
know um
i was uh i got the news uh i got a call
and i called gene um and we you know
celebrated it was really lovely and i
asked her i said
um well gene what am i supposed to do
with the rest of my day you know this is
such a
a beautiful eruption of uh celebration
so early on what do we do what do we do
with the rest of the day and she just
said
i don't know go to the grocery store
just live your life
just get out there do what you got to do
hannah i want to follow up on what
jerica said
about you because i love this show i was
just going to watch one episode because
my
son was raving about it and before i
knew it i'd i'd gotten through six and i
know there's more to come
you are so knockout in it and i was so
bummed that we weren't going to see you
in person face to face because i really
really wanted to meet you
but do you how do you connect to her
because
listen i don't know you've never met you
but you play her so seamlessly
and i'm thinking what are you really
really like you connected to her right
away
this this ava character oh you want to
talk about clothes
yeah um she is she is fierce
in a way that i really admire um i did
connect to her right away
you know she has such a strong
personality and point of view and she
was so
vivid the second i read her you know in
the first couple scenes of the show
itself reading those scripts it was very
clear to me
you know who she was and where she was
coming from and
i i admired her right off the bat and i
felt connected to her certainly as like
a queer character that felt really
fleshed out and like i said really vivid
which is not something that you know
i i read all the time in all honesty so
it was really refreshing
um to see and what about you and gene
smart together because your your put
downs of each other
are very are next level in this show
which is also fun to watch oh um
oh thank you yeah i mean gene and i
it's i would say that the the deborah
eva dynamic in terms of the
sort of like comedy jabs is kind of a
one-to-one
we love kind of that that like quippy
playful sparring um
and she's just i mean in terms of our
dynamics she's just become
one of my dear friends and like like a
big sis i love her so much
i get it for people who haven't seen
your stand-up comedy in person
how do you describe your style and your
sense of humor
um okay hannah don't sound like a
like a narcissist here how do we go
ahead hannah go ahead
i'm like i'm like how do i come how do i
um well
i mean it's a it's a little
stylistically all over the place
i try to dip my toes into every
style comedically i like to do music i
like to do
you know a lighting cue a prop here and
there break up the form
get weird experimental here and there um
you know just sort of we like the latest
bit i wrote is
um sort of uh it's like biology
uh based so i'll just go all over the
place i'm not really doing like uh
a lot of like um dating is
weird i'm not really doing okay not that
i mean i love to watch that hannah what
did you want i just kind of go in the
weird spaces what made you want to get
into stand-up in the first place
um you know i kind of i i started doing
improv
in uh in college and
um there was a comedian nicole byer
who i'm a huge fan of she's fantastic
and she came to
to my school and she asked if anyone
from the improv team wanted to open for
her
and uh i volunteered and i just kind of
um
tried it out in that way and i fell in
love with it and then you know after
after college i just started going open
mics around
la and the rest is as they say
herstory hannah cheering you on i can't
wait for emmy knight
i mean i you you really the show is so
good and so
funny and you are knockout in it so very
happy for your nomination thank you
congratulations thank you gail you're so
cool thank you rock
i feel the same about you i feel the
same about you very nice to meet you
coming up on today's cbs this morning
podcast we're going to talk with two of
the co-creators of hacks
that's lucia and ayanello and paul
and yellow and yellow and yellow
and paul w down that's them the real
life couple discusses how they cast
hannah and jean smart for the title
roles